scientists in Oklahoma are one step
closer to finding possible evidence of
mass graves linked to one of the worst
incidents of racial violence in our
country's history
researchers in Tulsa use
ground-penetrating radar to server' to
survey three sites they found
irregularities at two of those sites
that could be consistent with
large-scale burials Omar Villafranca is
in Tulsa Omar this could ultimately
uncover a new chapter in American
history that most people have never ever
heard of good morning to you you're
right it good morning your and not just
Black History you're right this is
American history this is the Greenwood
neighborhood also known as Black Wall
Street you had tailors banks grocery
stores tax services all black owned
businesses but in 1921 a white mob
burned it to the ground and as many as
300 black residents were killed that's
what's depicted there on the letter K
history had basically almost forgotten
about this but the city of Tulsa is
digging up the past and trying to heal
old wounds this was all part of yes the
Greenwood air yes the building set where
his parking lot was photojournalist
Kevin Ross says he's grateful that a
tragic little-known part of Tulsa
history is now coming to light for
decades it was huss huss even some of
the survivors that I interviewed they
were quiet and tongue oh and a white
people they whispered in all homes
because they were brought brought up not
talking about what happened it happened
on these streets in 1921 much of the
Tulsa neighborhood of Greenwood was
burned to the ground by a white mob the
group clashed with several armed black
men who had gathered to protect a black
shoe-shiner
who was unjustly accused of assaulting a
white woman after a shot was fired
violence broke out and hundreds of black
people were massacred
Ross's great-grandfather was forced to
flee the city after his business was
destroyed he had explosions you had
people running for their lives it was
just it was just hell on earth
the horror was brought to life in the
premiere episode of HBO's new series
Watchmen witnesses reported seeing
bodies put in mass graves but local
officials hid evidence of any crimes
along the fence line at a public forum
Monday scientists confirmed they
discovered what appears to be an
underground pit roughly thirty by 25
feet which they say is large enough to
bury up to a hundred bodies but I'm as
confident as I can be and the results
that this is this is a very good
candidate for something associated with
with the massacre GT Bynum is Tulsa's
mayor it's very powerful it's the first
time that we've had anyone say that in
from a technical standpoint in an open
forum and meeting like this or to us
scientists are now planning to do
additional surveys that could lead to
excavations we don't know what the
preservation will be like and even if
the preservation is truly excellent we
don't know who we'll find in there how
soon would you like to see excavation I
would like to see the excavation by the
spring you know we waited this long we
know where they are let's go get to them
the city wants to continue scanning
early next year now to give you a little
bit more perspective 35 blocks were
burned to the ground one of the few
things that survived that Massacre was
the basement of this church here
everything you see above ground was
built afterwards and church leaders in
this community say if remains are found
they want them relocated here to the
black Wall Street area and they want to
build a room Memorial Tony what I'd be
appropriate Omar thank you very much now
this was deliberately kept out of
textbooks for years so what's happening
now is a powerful recommend important
piece of history that should not be
forgotten zakir it's a stunning story
I'd only heard about it ten years ago
and I was embarrassed that I'd never
heard it but either of you a friend of
mine a couple years ago had said you all
should really look into doing a piece on
black Wall Street in because it is
something that you don't necessarily
hear a lot about
[Music]